Новини дня «heute» з Мітрі Сіріним.
Доброго вечора всім.
Катя Штрезо знову зі мною
з найважливішими новинами спорту.
Доброго вечора.
У спорті сьогодні є «гаряча тема».
Згодом поговоримо про це детальніше.
Крім цього ми підготували такі теми:
Після тижнів облоги:
«Азовсталь» у Маріуполі
залишають останні українські бійці.
Громадський транспорт за 9 євро:
лише тимчасове рішення чи перший крок до
переходу на екологічне користування транспортом?
І несподіваний розрив лише після
одного спільного сезону:
віце-чемпіон «Дортмунд» припиняє співпрацю
зі своїм головним тренером Марком Розе.
Маріуполь, портове місто на півдні,
та його металургійний завод,
який став символом опору загарбницькій війні Росії,
вочевидь, залишають його захисники.
Український уряд, очевидно, наказав бійцям,
які там залишилися, припинити оборону.
Росія все сильніше обстрілює Донбас.
Більше розповість Юрґен Кель.
На сході України Росія застосовує
гордість своєї армії -
реактивну систему залпового вогню «Град».
Міністерство оборони Росії демонструє відео
як звіт про перебіг війни.
У Москві міністр Шойгу заявляє:
Незабаром ми,
разом із військами ДНР та ЛНР,
візьмемо під контроль територію Донбасу.
Прямо на лінії фронту розташований Сєвєродонецьк,
який все ще перебуває під контролем України.
Зараз саме час покинути цю небезпечну зону.
Україна показує відео, на якому українські силовики
розсаджують дітей у автобуси.
«Не бійся, гаразд?
Все буде добре» -
каже солдат маленькій дівчинці.
«Бережи себе»
Люди довго чекали, сподіваючись,
що фронт не наблизиться до них.
Але військовий тиск із боку Росії зростає.
Cитуація в Маріуполі, схоже, вирішилася
на користь загарбників.
Після тижнів облоги росіяни повідомляють
про понад 1700 полонених.
Ось відео з минулої ночі.
Інформації з Києва щодо цього немає,
проте, очевидно, є наказ для командира полку,
частина якого закріпилася на території заводу.
Сам він у своєму відеозверненні каже:
Вище військове керівництво дало наказ
про збереження життя
та припинення оборони міста.
Поки не зрозуміло, чи завершується на цьому облога міста.
Якщо так, то росіяни тепер матимуть
додаткові війська для боїв на сході України.
Президент Зеленський говорить про
«пекло» на Донбасі,
Росія ж повідомляє про успіхи на цьому напрямку.
Поспілкуємося з Йоганнесом Гано, який зараз у Києві.
Як ситуація на сході України?
Практично по всій Україні сьогодні
лунала повітряна тривога.
Зокрема, декілька разів у столиці.
Уранці під Києвом було збито російську ракету.
В Одесі та багатьох інших містах лунали потужні вибухи.
Це російський ракетний терор.
Але тут люди вже до цього звикли.
Зовсім іншою є ситуація на Донбасі, де росіяни
з допомогою важкої артилерії
вибивають кожен населений пункт,
щоб оточити українські війська.
Останні як можуть намагаються протистояти
але сил, вочевидь, стає все менше.
Я маю неофіційне підтвердження, що
втрати українців там є значно більшими,
ніж повідомляють офіційні джерела.
Важливо, як ситуація розвиватиметься надалі.
Росіяни хочуть оточити ЗСУ на Сході.
Якщо їм це вдасться, це буде військова катастрофа
для України,
яка може повністю змінити хід війни.
Довгий час було незрозуміло,
коли саме Україна отримає обіцяні танки типу «Гепард».
За даними ZDF, 15 таких зенітних танків
буде передано Україні в середині липня.
До пакету також входять навчання
за підтримки Бундесверу,
а також - боєприпаси.
Щоб полегшити життя громадян,
«світлофорна» коаліція запропонувала низку законів,
які сьогодні ухвалив Бундесрат.
Полегшення стосується податків та електроенергії.
Більше про це - за мить.
З 1-го червня буде на 3 місяці введено
квиток вартістю 9 євро
на всі види громадського транспорту.
Проте є сумніви щодо того, чи дійсно це, як заявляє уряд,
буде початком радикальних змін транспортної системи.
Одна з найкрасивіших ліній метро в Німеччині -
це лінія U3 біля набережної Ландунґсбрюкен у Гамбурзі.
Такий популярний серед туристів маршрут
з 1-го червня також підпадає під квиток за 9 євро.
Від сьогодні пільговий місячний квиток можна придбати
у додатку, квиткових автоматах
та повсюди у клієнтських центрах.
Я вважаю, що це хороша ідея,
адже інакше громадський транспорт став
занадто дорогим.
На мою думку, потужностей залізниці
може бути недостатньо.
Вона може не впоратися з напливом людей,
які захочуть скористатися квитком.
Квиток буде дійсний по всій Німеччині.
Навіть якщо його купили в Гамбурзі чи Мюнхені,
ним можна буде скористатися, наприклад, в Дрездені.
Квиток дійсний для усього громадського транспорту,
крім IC, EC та ICE.
Це також і потужна реклама
для громадського транспорту і ми дуже раді,
що нам вдалося переконати окремі
федеральні землі ввести такі квитки.
Деякі з земель Німеччини до останнього вимагали
вищої ціни на громадський транспорт.
Восени рішення щодо квитка за 9 євро
знову обговорюватимуть.
Транспортні компанії зацікавлені, щоб їхні послуги
стали привабливішими.
Йдеться про розбудову транспортної мережі,
про електрифікацію
автобусних парків, про більшу злагодженість
та нові транспортні пропозиції.
Саме їхнє створення є вирішальним пунктом.
У великих містах, як-от Гамбург, це простіше.
Але в структурно слабших регіонах іноді
ходить лише два автобуси на день.
Навіть пороми вздовж набережної Ландунґсбрюкен
в Гамбурзі курсують частіше.
Цей круїз із 1-го червня також входить
у вартість квитка за 9 євро.
Щодо транспорту: АЗС вже попереджають, що
1-го червня можуть бути великі
черги до бензоколонок.
Можливо, навіть не всі охочі зможуть заправитися,
адже в цей день повинна знизитися ціна на пальне.
Парламент та Федеральна Рада також ухвалили
рішення про зниження податку.
«Super» може здешевшати на 35 центів,
дизель - на 17 центів.
Хоча знижка й діє лише до кінця серпня,
вона повинна стати
помічною передусім для тих,
хто живе далеко від місця роботи.
Уряд Німеччини хоче відмовитися від російського газу,
тому потребує нових постачальників.
Один з них - емір Катару, шейх Тамім Аль Тані -
був сьогодні в Берліні.
З 2024 року Катар хоче поставляти Німеччині
зріджений газ
через газобалонну установку США,
до якої він теж доєднаний.
А згодом - природний газ із родовища Перської затоки.
Міністр енергетики Катару та
міністр економіки Німеччини Габек
підписали договір про енергетичне партнерство.
На останніх виборах до земельних парламентів
партіям SPD і FDP не надто пощастило.
Дуже хочеться поглянути на свіжі цифри
політичного барометра ZDF.
Зараз із нами Матіас Форнофф.
Матіасе, яке значення це «недільне питання»
має на державному рівні?
На політичному ландшафті спостерігається активний рух.
Якби цієї неділі були вибори до Бундестагу,
SPD набрала б 22% - на 3% менше.
Коаліція виходить на перше місце - 26%, +3%.
У Зелених - 24%, теж +3%.
У FDP - 7%, -2%.
У AfD - 10%, -1%.
У Лівих - незмінно 4%.
Таким чином, стала б можливою чорно-зелена
або й червоно-зелена коаліція.
А тепер до питання поставок важкого озброєння Україні,
яке останнім часом є причиною палких дискусій.
Що думають респонденти щодо цього?
Те, що Німеччина постачатиме Україні
важке озброєння, як-от танки,
більшість, а саме - 58%, вважає правильним.
34% не згодні з цим.
На Заході країни такі поставки підтримують 62%,
на Сході - лише 41%.
Через російську агресію проти України
Фінляндія та Швеція подали заявки на вступ до НАТО.
До такого північного розширення НАТО
81% опитаних ставляться позитивно,
13% - негативно.
Дякую, Матіасе.
Як завжди, детальний політичний огляд
Ви побачите в «heute journal» о 22:00
або ж уже зараз у нашому додатку «ZDFheute».
Колишній канцлер Шрьодер пішов
з посади голови наглядової ради
російської нафтогазової компанії «Роснефть».
Це є великою несподіванкою,
адже останнім часом він міцно тримався за цю посаду.
Його сильно критикували за те, що після початку війни
він не віддалився від Путіна
або ж не розірвав зв'язки з російськими компаніями.
Про можливі мотиви такого рішення ми поговоримо
з Тео Коллем, Берлін.
Тео, чому лише тепер, а не раніше?
Вимогу Європарламенту було висунуто від імені
4-х найбільших фракцій,
в тому числі й від соціал-демократів.
Це був важливий попереджувальний сигнал.
Хоча канцлер Шольц і не бачить причини
для накладення санкцій на Шрьодера,
проте ця резолюція ЄС засвідчила наявну політичну динаміку, за якої,
поруч із іншими 4000 особами,
під санкції може потрапити й екс-канцлер.
І якщо це станеться, то для Ґергарда Шрьодера,
який звик до розкошів, це буде сильним ударом.
Адже в такому разі його статки
на європейських рахунках,
включно з подальшими надходженнями,
буде заморожено.
Тоді в нього залишаться гроші лише на найнеобхідніше:
одяг, медикаменти та їжу.
Будь-які фінансові операції буде контролювати
Федеральний банк Німеччини.
Усьому цьому він, власне, й хотів запобігти.
На перший погляд, це дивує,
адже Шрьодер уже давно поплатився
за свої дії зневагою суспільства.
Зокрема, було закрито його офіс в Бундестазі
та наявні там робочі місця.
Проте втратити доступ до власних статків -
це було для нього вже занадто.
Бундесвер залишиться
довше в західноафриканській країні - Малі.
Бундестаг продовжив мандат на 1 рік.
У майбутньому
в операції «Блакитних касок» ООН
зможуть взяти участь
до 1400 німецьких солдатів,
а не 1100 як раніше.
У випадку, якщо їхня безпека
буде під питанням
у новому мандаті є пункт про відмову.
На сьогодні метеорологи прогнозують бурю
з регіональними сильними грозами
та сильними поривами.
Спочатку з осередками над
Північним Рейном-Вестфалією
та Рейнланд-Пфальцем.
Потім фронт посунувся далі на схід.
Нині негода на лінії між Люнебурзькою пусткою
та Північною Баварією.
Крістоф Дестайрел розпочинає
свій репортаж у Рейнланд-Пфальці.
Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлер - сьогодні вдень дощ,
але рівень води нормальний,
Ар тече спокійно.
У одному з курортних будинків розбиті вікна,
зруйнована стіна.
Це старі пошкодження після катастрофи рік тому.
Але поглянувши на це, розумієш,
чому жителі зараз нервуються.
Колись люди насолоджувалися грозами,
а тепер ми просто боїмося.
Наскільки складно зараз розібратися з погодою,
показує порівняння:
нормальна кількість опадів
в Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлері,
але всього за 40 км
нижче від цієї картинки:
Град в Нойвіді близько 5:30 ранку.
Як неприємно.
І далі на північ:
Північний Рейн-Вестфалія, Падерборн.
Один грозовий осередок перетворюється
на торнадо, повідомляють місцеві жителі.
Дерева тріщать, гілки, сміття,
всілякі предмети кружляють навколо.
Як кажуть,
успіх чи невдача можуть бути
в декількох кварталах одне від одного.
Грози зараз рухаються із заходу на схід.
Поки що не повідомляється
про серйозні пошкодження або травми,
але до пізньої ночі
все може раптово змінитися.
Ми хотіли б детальніше поговорити про це
з нашим метеорологом Озденом Терлі.
Вітаю, Оздене, зазвичай такі бурі
починаються з липня або серпня.
Чому зараз вже такі сильні бурі?
Це пов'язано з гарячим повітрям,
яке зараз над Іспанією та Францією
і також дійшло до нас.
Крім того, було відносно холодне повітря з півночі.
Це була вибухонебезпечна суміш,
що призвела до цього.
Екстремальна погода посилюється. Міжурядова
група експертів зі зміни клімату підтверджує це.
Що далі? Куди зараз прямує буря?
На зйомці з супутника ми бачимо,
як грозові осередки рухаються
на схід, в напрямку Берліна.
Ці червоні плями над Німеччиною -
суперосередки.
Ми бачимо - це ще далеко не кінець.
Вони рухаються в напрямку Берліна.
Це, ймовірно,
завдасть досить великої шкоди і там.
Дякую, Оздене Терлі.
У Німеччині зареєстровано
перший випадок захворювання на віспу мавп.
Вірус був встановлений в одного пацієнта,
оголосило МОЗ Баварії.
Це 26-річний бразилець.
Він перебуває в Німеччині вже тиждень
і на даний момент проходить лікування
в одній із клінік Мюнхена.
Звідти повідомляє Петра Нойбауер:
Наразі перший хворий на віспу мавп гарно ізольований.
Він лікується у мюнхенській клініці Швабінг:
26-річний хлопець в'їхав до Німеччини
з Португалії через Іспанію,
його стан наразі хороший.
У нього на шкірі пустули,
характерні для віспи мавп,
але серйозної загрози немає.
Ми припускаємо, що пацієнт
заразився на єропейському материку.
Існує всього кілька записів про цю хворобу,
що виникла у тваринному світі.
До цих пір людські інфекції були виявлені
в деяких регіонах Африки,
але тепер випадки захворювання накопичуються
в Північній Америці та Європі.
Перебіг зазвичай легкий.
На даний момент немає стандартної терапії,
тобто якогось одного препарату,
чогось на зразок антибіотиків,
але є противірусні засоби, що
діють на різні віруси
і їх можна тут використати.
В основному це захворювання вражає людей
з численними сексуальними контактами,
і чоловіків-гомосексуалістів.
Зрештою, класичне щеплення від віспи,
яке отримали всі, хто народився
до 1976 року, має захищати.
Тому молоді люди будуть у зоні ризику.
Федеральний міністр охорони здоров'я
не бачить причин для паніки.
Я не припускаю,
що в Німеччині існує велика кількість
незареєстрованих випадків,
я вважаю, що це дуже ранній випадок,
і якщо це так,
ми зможемо тримати ситуацію під контролем.
Поки неможливо сказати,
наскільки швидко поширюватиметься віспа мавп.
Зараз важливо збирати дані
та бути напоготові у разі появи симптомів.
Американська аерокосмічна компанія Boeing
хоче скласти конкуренцію Ілону Маску
та його космічній компанії Space-X.
Багаторазовий космічний корабель
Boeing Starliner
був запущений на ракеті Atlas
з космодрому на мисі Канаверал до МКС.
Перший раз без людей на борту.
Остання спроба 2,5 роки тому
була невдалою.
Скоро Starliner доставить астронавтів
та матеріали на МКС.
А тепер поговоримо про спорт з Катею.
Для більшості людей
цей крок став несподіванкою.
Після майже року співпраці
шляхи «Борусії Дортмунд» і
тренера Марко Розе розійшлися.
Розе перейшов з «Гладбаху»
за 5 млн грн.
Менеджери «BVB» таким чином
реагують на невдалий сезон:
Виліт із Ліги чемпіонів,
виліт із Кубку «DFB» проти «Санкт-Паулі»
і, як наслідок, неможливість захистити свій титул.
Другий у Бундеслізі,
але з прикрим відставанням у 8 очок
від чемпіона «Баварії».
Тож закономірна критика
призвела до припинення ділових відносин:
кандидатом у наступники може стати
нинішній технічний директор Едін Терзіч:
Він став володарем Кубка «BVB» з «DFB»
у 2021 році як тимчасовий тренер.
А також розглядається тренер Люсьєн Фавр,
котрий повернувся з Бундесліги,
до «Боруссія Менхенгладбах»,
яка шукає тренера
після відставки Аді Хюттера.
Фавр вже був тренером «Гладбах»
з 2011 по 2015 рік.
У першій грі на виліт у Бундеслізі
між «Hertha BSC» та «Hamburger SV»,
«HSV» випередив з рахунком 1:0.
Берлінці в білому не демонструють особливої сили.
«HSV» забив щасливий гол
за допомогою внутрішньої стійки
на 57-й хвилині.
Матч у відповідь відбудеться
в понеділок у Гамбурзі.
Збірна Німеччини з хокею
чітко тримає курс на вихід
до чвертьфіналу чемпіонату світу у Фінляндії
завдяки сьогоднішній перемозі над Італією
з рахунком 9:4.
Справжнє свято голів розпочинається за 5 хвилин.
Олександр Карачун першим побив рекорд
Італії з катання на ковзанах.
4:0 проти
безпрограшних претендентів
на виліт після першої третини.
У другому періоді забиває Лукас Райхель,
який тільки
напередодні прибув із другої професійної ліги США.
Декілька ключових гравців
пошкодував німецький тренерський штаб,
до якого вперше увійшла жінка,
Джессіка Кемпбелл з Канади.
Перед останнім періодом вони ведуть 6:1,
пропускають ще три голи,
але Самуель Сораміс забиває дев'ятий гол.
Німеччина виграє
з рахунком 9:4 і дуже
близька до чвертьфіналу.
Вони будуть у ньому в неділю,
якщо виграють у Казахстана,
що займатиме останнє місце в групі -
отже, виглядає цілком непогано.
Дякую, Катю.
Щодо погоди в Саксонії,
будь ласка, будьте обережні,
докладніше про це за хвилину - Озден Терлі.
О 22:00 «heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
На цьому у нас все.
Дякую за ваш інтерес
та бажаю гарного вечора, до завтра.
Доброго вечора і ласкаво просимо
до прогнозу погоди.
Завтра ввечері та вночі,
у найближчі кілька годин
ми очікуємо екстремальних бурь.
Можливі урагани,
сильні зливи, великий град, до 5 см,
або поодинокі торнадо під час грози.
Але це відбуватиметься локально,
тобто, в цій області,
але не скрізь.
Подивимось, як це сталося?
Цей циклон поступово
розвивався і посилювався,
у другій половині дня та у
вечірні години він переміщатиметься далі.
На півдні все ще йде сильний дощ,
а також в центральній частині
місцями можливий сильний вітер,
частково з ураганами.
Завтра зливи та грози на півночі та півдні,
на решті територій сонячно
температура сягне 16-18° на півночі
та 27° на південному заході.
Наступні дні:
зливи та грози на півдні
в неділю до 26°,
на решті територій ясно.
В понеділок очікуються
нові урагани на півдні
з грозами за температури від 20 до 27°.
Гарного вечора!